好
我们继续
所以你不管任何的一个自动化流程
都是从我们这里取数据的
只不过CS的那个是针对实验室这个场景做的
它其实是不是场景的配置
还是实际的实验业就是业务运行的
对不对
对对对
明白了
对所以他是这样一个逻辑
然后后面的话我们不是还要做奶茶什么那些的原因
其实他其实所有的数据源都是从这里来的
那这个有没有一个已经配好的数据
演示的项目什么看一下
到时候周斌给一个呗
好的
啥
刚刚没听到我啥
这个任务
就是你配置过的那个那个任务流的对
给一个示例
是的
给个视频
给个有数据的看一下是怎样的
那还不如直接用我最新做的那个得了
可以
用你最新做的可以
都行反正就是给颜色演示一下
因为他马上也要设计那个
好好的
我们先做了一版原型
然后到时候你看一下
然后再优化那个交互
那我我我要我现在共享屏幕看看一下
那可以
那最好
你共享
那那那施工这边退一下
我们现在项目排的有点压力大
所以都等不到你这边设计结果了
都得往前赶
我也很忙
所以之前年前为什么着急找你就是但是老板说还是找你这个
因为统一套风格
那那我共享一下
你共享
对
因为现在我们这些项目都是已经中标了的
而且朱平现在手上在做这个
都是已经签了
要交付的
对所以有一些东西可能就等不到你的设计
但是不影响他还是继续往前做
可以
能能看到
看到就是很大
就是大概我的设计思路是这样
首先我们有自己的邮政图吗
然后这里可能会编一些非常细节的操作
里面涉及到是非常原始和底层的一些操作
就比如说你点位这里那些这里
形成了一段工作流对吧
我想给外面用
但是我又不希望让终端用户或者是说售后
或者是说调试人员看到这么多细节
我现在的做法是放一个触发模块
然后比如说我这里是一版操作
怎么都好一般操作
然后我可能只需要暴露几个参数给外面
比如说第一个
我想从哪一个版位来源
版位输入框最大值
最小值再给他一个目标岗位
输入框18
好然后这个时候我把这个任务暴露出去
然后在我这个页面我就可以加载到刚刚的这个操作
这个操作现在只有2个35度
这样的话更就就更方便我们开发人员的上一层使用
哦啊四维
应该能理解
就是这里更细节对吧
更细节它可能涉及到机械臂
电机还有一些乱七八糟的其他东西
我给终端用户
比如说一个做实验的人
他可能根本就不关心这些东西
对他关心的是更加上一层的一些动作
对
什么版到哪里是吧
对对对
然后这个你提供几个哪些参数给外面
就是说你根据实际的情况
在这里去添加删除这些东西
就相当于你在那边写好了一个
然后勾选一下暴露在这边
他在对对对
然后在这里又有一个简单的这样的流程
也就这个流程更简单
更方便那种没有什么调试经验或者说售后人员去使用
这个就是方便我们开发人员
就是说这个从0到1的这种人员去用的这种模式
视为可以参考一下
对
那其实就不需要在那边还有这个面板的对吧
刚刚对这个你看这个是一样的
看到没有出现
但是你这个设计的话就相当于整个现在看到的这个黑豹OS的这个三三大模块的这些界面
这些东西他们是不需要看到的是吧
对
在新的我这是我做的原型
这个肯定看不到
就包括我那天不是给你看实验
是管理我们未来要做的那个大系统
它里面也会有周斌现在这一个模块
然后对它它也不需要看到我们的底层的那个
你可以理解为就是两套
对两这两个东西是有接口关联的
我们这种更方便于开发人员各方面终端的用户
对对对对我觉得然后
包括这个实验流程
包括一些4G的参数
4G的那些配置都在这边
对
到时候我这个主页没有做
我当时的想法是说每个项目这个主页用一种就是把台面上面的所有东西
用一张图片或者是什么东西显示在这里
然后每个区域可以
根据我们我对
我给你看的我们那个布局图就那天给你的视频这个单
里面生成的对
对对对对对对
类似那样的方式
对
然后在这里就是用户自己定义的工艺流程也好
实验流程也好
他点进去直接运行就是可以运行
就不用再关心这里面到底有哪些东西了
然后这些是配合终端调试的界面
这个就先大概是这个样子
OK
可以参考一下
然后刚刚那个
就是实验流程里面进去的是吗
实验流程
这边就是说用户先有一个实验
先定义一个实验
比如说分子组装
对
好
然后他可能有一个描述
这是一个
干什么
的实验
好创建完了以后
这个没关系
创建完了就是创建完了以后就是这个东西一个块儿
我现在跟陆风是想用这种卡片的形式展示
然后你有什么更好的设计
到时候就提供给我们
然后在这里点完以后
这里有一排按钮
删除B编辑
然后进入大的流程图
大致流程图的来源就是我刚刚跟你讲的这个模式
那它编辑什么
编辑刚刚的名称吗
对对对
OK然后
到时候下面也会放一排这个按钮
让他直接可以在这里运行
那你这个你
不用去说我说的啥
你怎么设计
你按你的想法
反正我我我设计的整个流程我知道我知道了
就先参考一下你的
对我要真正的去带入那个业务场景是什么
我才能够给一些
对对对
然后你也可以看那天我给你的那几个视频
然后你都可以看一下
反正我们的应用需求就是这个
好好的
我觉得这个可能得很厚
有点后了
这个先
那反正就是我我跟你说
你就当一个开发项目来搞
我们今年反正至少目标就是我们上半年已经中标交付的这些项目都会用这一套东西的
好啊好的
对
然后目前签下来的有一些的
比如说几个大的
有七月份交付的
也有六月份
交付的对对
好
朱斌现在在做这个算是一个小项目
他先练练手
不涉及这个大的系统
但是六月份七月份的都是整个实验室这种大的
所以那个设计肯定要出来
就肯定要更早的出来给他们做开发
好的
行还​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌有其他不是的
应该没有了
好的
那先就这些
我就先把前面的那个
对
然后如果你有什么比如说刚才说的这种环境的需求
比如说你要看什么的
你就在群里提到时候我来给你协调资源吧
好
好好好的
行那先这样
好好
行拜拜